today I'm going to show you how to make
one of my favorite easy gut healing
breakfast starch is one of the things
that can really irritate the gut now IBS
symptoms are super tricky everyone's
experience of what triggers a flare will
ultimately be unique but generally
speaking we know that starchy foods are
hugely beneficial for the gut if we look
at resistant starch for example from
foods like bananas potatoes oats rice
plantains legumes these are all starchy
higher carb foods that act as a
Prebiotic fiber to prove gut health
microbiome diversity short chain fatty
acid production and immune response I
totally can see why Liz's kind of Keto
carnivore style diet has reduced her GI
symptoms it's because she's cut out a
lot of potentially triggering foods but
elimination diets like the controversial
gaps diets that she references in the
description are not meant to be followed
long term you're supposed to eliminate
and then reintroduce most of the foods
that you cut out in a stepwise manner so
as Not to cause long-term harm to the
microbiome